good morning to you as you can see
deputy prime minister is with us this
morning i want to talk about tributes
being paid to the conservative mp so
david amis in the house of commons later
on thanks for joining us good morning
how do you remember him
well the last event i did with him was
at conference and he was the most
tenacious animal welfare campaigner he'd
been uh passing private members bills
since the 80s on looking after animals
he was still doing it very much of the
vanguard of it he was a kind decent man
very much known as sort of mr essex mr
south end but he defied caricature he
was big-hearted uh he came down just
last month for the 10-year anniversary
of my conservative women's organization
event he was incredibly energetic
but what really defined him is that even
when he disagreed with people there was
uh a generosity of spirit and uh we'll
miss him and i'll miss him personally he
was very very kind generous with his
time and advice ever since i've been in
the house of commons
it's not a one-off though is it uh two
mps in five years what needs to change
well i think the first thing to say is
we've i was contacted by my local police
over the weekend all mps will be getting
those calls just to check in we
appreciate that i certainly found it
reassuring i think everyone's in a
slightly different position everyone's
got different circumstances so i don't
want to sort of speak for others my own
personal feeling is we need to do our
due diligence we need to think about how
available we are and make sure we're not
at undue risk but no one wants and i
certainly don't want to wedge put
between me and the people that elect me
and the people that i'm voted in to
serve and i think a lot of people feel
that way so plain clothes officers at
surgeries
well i guess it depends on the
individual i think we're more likely to
look at things like private security
guards there's already i believe uh uh
money available for that um but again
the problem you've got is a lot of
people coming to see their mp it's quite
a thing to do it takes quite a bit of
courage they'll feel sensitive about it
they'll feel vulnerable itself you do
not want to add to that sense of
foreboding as they're waiting for
example for constituency surgery on the
other hand we are and this is the nature
of the modern age very much out there
we're available we advertise everything
we're doing in a much uh you know online
and all the rest of it um so i think we
need to think about a proportionate
risk-based approach and that will vary
from person to person i think the the
other thing of course the elephant in
the room and all this is the amount of
online hate uh
that we all get um it's out of control i
know the home secretary has talked to
about what more she wants to do there
the online harms bill is going through
pre-legislative scrutiny um we you know
i'm a free speech man i i want to defend
that
to my dying days but at the same time um
i think the amount of vile abuse and the
vilification directed at mv's and in
particular female mps i think it's got
to stop let me take you back if i made
uh deputy prime minister to uh whether
there should be uh playing clothes
officers though do you think there
should be or not i probably wouldn't
choose to have them outside a surgery um
that i had i think uh
i would worry about the chilling effect
i'm i'm not sure it's necessary um to
have that that those members potentially
i suppose women and members of
parliament who wanted them you wouldn't
stand in the way oh come on no no no
look i think i can't sit here and
legislate or prescribe for every mp i
think anyone that has um a real
nervousness a concern we need to and the
force is already doing this uh the local
force needs to sit down with them and
see what they can do to provide the
concrete security i mean the objective
security but also what will give them
reassurance and peace of mind we're not
going to be much good for our
constituents if we're not confident
going into those meetings
and if we're all looking over our
shoulder with trepidation
i don't know if you've seen i'm sure you
have seen the front page of the times
newspaper this morning um the um qatar
trip last week it was a meeting with the
taliban amongst others
and of course the david was was part of
that um trip some of those on the trip
feel anxious about it as a result should
they be offered more security
well i'm going to be very careful what i
say about the case of sir david because
the police need the time and space to
conduct their investigation and i don't
want to say anything that could remotely
be perceived as prejudicing any further
prosecution but look if anyone is
nervous whether it's in relation to
foreign trips
or the advocacy they do here in the uk
they should talk to their local police
or forces and see what more can be done
there's
a lot of talk uh over the weekend and
also in the newspapers this morning
about post-pandemic radicalism what does
that mean to you
well these terms
people come up with them but i think
what we saw over the period of the
pandemic is a huge amount of additional
activity online um and people using
online whether it's for the work life
balance whether it's for educating their
kids in a way that was for the for the
large part was a great relief and a
great
solace given what we're all going
through with the pandemic people could
talk to their
grandparents their young children in
ways or
or relatives in ways that we hadn't done
before but there is also a dark side to
what happens online and i suspect a lot
of people um or or as well as
experiencing the positives there will
have been just moments where people were
anxious we know that
those with mental health
struggled during the pandemic and
although crime as a result came down
overall because there's less people on
the streets and all the rest of it we
know that there was at least some extra
nefarious activity online so i i
wouldn't want to dub the whole of what
happens online in a negative way it's
hugely emancipating in many ways but i
think in the pandemic it really
magnified the positive but also some of
the vulnerabilities and that's what
we're working through yeah but i mean
there are shadows who are being
radicalized by even bigger shadows
during the pandemic and it seems there's
not much we can do about it well look
there is certainly i think uh an element
of uh more people who are at risk
vulnerable or at risk of radicalization
would have been spending more time
online i'm absolutely confident that the
intelligence agencies and the police are
monitoring that with maximum energy and
vigor i know from uh
my time working on the the national
security council's foreign secretary
and and now uh how hard they work but of
course they've got to adapt to a
different set of circumstances but but
they're on the case um they do an
incredible job i don't think anyone does
a better job but but what you're really
seeing is behavior morphing um and
changing and obviously we've got to
adapt and and uh respond to that yeah i
suppose what i'm really asking is
whether the prevent program is still fit
for purpose well prevents much broader
than just the online piece um
look it's being reviewed at the moment
by the home secretary uh for the best
part three years and that's right look
the what i say more generally about it
it does have the ability to triage up to
what are known as channel panels which
has an interagency input so all the
different arms of government and local
government when there is a risk-based uh
assessment and to take proportion action
in relation to it but there is never
going to be a hundred percent safety net
against those that wish to harness what
we've got is a series of mitigations a
series of mitigations and checks to do
everything we can to keep us safe but
there is there is no risk free society
in a in a free society that where the
head of mi5 has consistently over many
years being clear about that
let's talk more about prevent um is it
fit for purpose well look i i don't
think there's ever a perfect
counter extremism strategy so we're
always looking at what we can do to
improve it as i say it's under review
the home secretary's been talking about
that you know when that might um come to
fruition well i'm not sure exactly um
the time frame for it but i know the
home secretary wants to i mean on the
one hand we want to get on with it uh
and learn the lessons for it on the
other hand i think particularly given
what we're going through now and the
questions are being asked i think it's
quite right that it takes into account
any lessons that we that we derive from
the current set of circumstances but you
would think three years is um i mean
it's well overdue
well i think there will be a case for um
setting it out more formally but of
course the reviews that we conduct it's
not like we're waiting till the end of
it to learn the lessons it is an
iterative process um so there's a whole
range of learning that right the way
through gets fed in to what the
obviously the intelligence agencies but
also down at the local authority level
and all the other different arms of
government and indeed the bodies at
local level including people talk about
schools uh what they pick up from local
nhs services so we do learn the lessons
as we go but in terms of coming up with
uh a formal
set of propositions or or learning from
it the home sector will decide the right
moment for that and obviously we want to
take into account everything that we've
uh
learnt from the pandemic but also of
course in relation to sir david no
better moment than um the second mp
being murdered in five years well that
will obviously
i'm sure crystallize the thinking around
what needs to be done what more needs to
be done but we come back i mean we've
looked at um prevent uh
for many years we've we've done lesson
learning uh uh reviews in the past
and
what i would say is it's a process we're
always looking to make sure as the
threat evolves we evolve with it as the
nature of the risks we face change we
adapt to it so in a way it's a process
it's not there's not going to be one
silver bullet that comes out and says
okay we're all going to be perfectly
safe we learn the lessons we build up
shore up the defenses and the
mitigations that we can possibly put in
place and we want to do it in a
proportionate way um so i think that's
the right approach
i just wanted to go back briefly if i
may on one of the comments that you made
about the pandemic and the lockdown and
it magnifying the vulnerables
does that mean that that potentially
people like you and your colleagues are
more at risk now than they were before
the pandemic i don't know whether i
would say we're more or less at risk to
be honest with you um since 2010 when i
first became an mp i've been very
conscious that the risk to us as
representatives has increased um i think
particularly uh at the local level i
think the from whom
well there's a whole range of things i
think there's um i mean you characterize
it certain way i think there's clearly a
lot of people with mental health issues
and the way uh mps are out there in the
public domain particularly the amount of
abuse we get they can become a lightning
rod for that who knows whether that has
an effect but i think we're all just
conscious that we as we
try and make sure we've got that
connection of trust with our
constituents and our communities which
most mps across the the divide will all
uh rally around and want to cherish and
nurture uh we're all trying to do the
best thing we can for our constituents
we have very different views about it i
think most of us would agree on that we
just don't want that wedge being put in
our way there's been a lot of there
being trust in politicians since the
expenses scandal there's other things
that come along and dent confidence
there's also the vilification the abuse
we all get and we work very hard to try
and connect uh with our constituents in
our communities and so as we do that of
course there's a risk that comes with it
so we've got to manage that sensibly
okay so how do you manage that sensibly
you say you're more vulnerable now in
the last decade than you were when you
first came into parliament um and that
can only presumably given the amount of
online hate that we witnessed in day out
that's only going to get worse
well i think there's no sign that the
abuse is abating but we're going to look
at that very carefully i think it's
incumbent on all of us mps the language
we use the media the language they use
and obviously the social media companies
it's not me passing the back i'm just
saying we've got a collective
responsibility and we've got to look at
the practical measures
or how we advertise ourselves it's
difficult because
most constituents don't think about
politics
very much every week most
swing voters most of the people who are
hardest to reach most of the vulnerable
we need to really go and advertise
ourselves but by doing that
we also advertise ourselves to everyone
else i think there's a proportionate
approach to this we look at the risk we
talk to our local police forces we
perhaps think about what we do and how
without allowing a wedge to be put in
there between us and our constituents
but also we just i mean this is the
number one thing we do not allow
something like this david amos would be
the first to set to uh to undermine to
corrode or erode our democracy it's
absolutely critical so we'll take the
targeted measures but we don't let the
terrorists uh win by creating wedges or
walls between us and those who go to sin
doesn't help when politicians call each
other things like scum though does it i
think it does but and i know what you're
referring to i think all of us it's
incumbent on all of us i think very
carefully about uh the way we uh
approach politics i always think that
you played the issue not the person uh
used to be said the man
not the ball not the man and it's
probably a bit sexist for the for the
current um uh uh uh political debate but
there is something in the fact and dave
and the the the thing that above all
over the weekend i've been thinking
about is there's no one that epitomized
that more than sir david amos he could
break bread with people from across the
aisles he had very strong views he was
catholic a brexiteer but he never
allowed uh uh himself to lose sight and
debate of treating someone else with
respect and i think part of that was the
empathy he had for other people but you
acknowledge that politicians should be
perhaps a little bit more careful about
the the words they choose to describe
each other we've been saying it for
years um and and and but i don't what i
don't want to do in the light of david's
death is for this to become uh partisan
uh it's an incumbent on all of us it's
incumbent on the media and again i'm not
trying to close down the space for
scrutiny of your elected representatives
that's what you're here for but i think
we all need to just think about are we
playing the issue or are we trying to
degrade the individual because there's
been too much of the latter and you
talked about social media as well um the
home secretary talked about trying to
have anonymous accounts closed down you
you second that
well i think we'll look at that what you
don't want to do is either send a
message to to tyrants all over the world
that they're that they can expose those
who are campaigning bravely and need
that anonymity equally we know that some
of those campaigning um uh are
vulnerable and will not want to be in
the public domain but i have to say that
on balance i think that there is a case
really for looking very carefully at
this i don't see why people should be
able to abuse the position on social
media
from a from a veil of anonymity
particularly given the consequences that
we're seeing and frankly even short of a
murder i just think and i look at it
from my female colleague's point of view
i know female colleagues of mine i'm
sure it's true across the parties who've
come off twitter because it's just so
vile um i think that can't be right and
i don't think that that is about free
speech i think it is narrowing the
debate for responsible public discourse
we just need to be careful about those
those boundaries okay um
i wondered if i could actually
particularly about what happened with um
sir david on friday um and
we believe that the priest was stopped
from giving him the last rights that
can't be right
i don't know any of the details around
that again i'm being really careful not
to speculate i know i know uh the i i i
don't know anything about it i'm
probably just better off not responding
to that although all i can say is i know
how uh
the paramedics on the scene work so hard
to try and keep him alive um so i again
without knowing the full facts forgive
me if i don't jump in and
but you would acknowledge how important
the last rights are to a devout catholic
of course of course i would
let me ask you uh about your comments
about legislating to correct court
judgments in human rights cases that go
against the government what's the
question very happy to do that so tell
me about it why do you feel that way
isn't it up to um judges and lawyers as
opposed to ministers well there's a
whole range of areas where we get
judgments that the parliament doesn't
agree with the separation of pounds is
very clear and i think this is a
criticism of the judiciary the judiciary
would say the same to me if parliament
doesn't like it vote to correct it and
we're looking very carefully at whether
we can formalize a mechanism or whether
we just do it bit by bit we're
uh if it wasn't for the tragic
circumstances i would be presenting a
judicial review and courts bill to the
house of commons today we'll be doing it
uh later this month uh one of the things
that we'll look at is um the number of
appeals in immigration tribunal cases
and whether after you've conducted those
appeals you can then even if they've
been unsuccessful go and judicial review
in the high court 750 of those cases a
year just three percent of those are
successful seems to me that that's a
good example of litigation by attrition
which is not serving the public interest
just before i let you go in your old job
uh you were very
much involved with what was happening
with nazin and zagari radcliff she's
lost her latest appeal against a second
jail sentence in iran it would be remiss
of me not to ask you
my heart goes out to nazi and i spoke to
her uh recently um look we are
absolutely clear and i know liz trust uh
and the foreign office team will
continue working uh as tenaciously as
ever to secure her release she's still
on furlough my understanding
so she's not in custody
and we call on iran to release all of
our arbitrarily detained nationals
and my heart is with the family